In 2004, I got a call
from LIFE magazine.
They said we have this
incredible assignment for you.
It's to photograph the wounded
coming out of Fallujah.
When we flew in
this is one of the
first scenes I saw.
This is on my birthday in 2004
and it was during the
Battle of Fallujah.
And there were so many wounded
Americans coming out of Fallujah
that they cleared out the
inside of a C-17 cargo aircraft
and put all the wounded
on the ground.
And this is how they flew them
to Germany for treatment.
And this is a young man who
was wounded in Fallujah
and that's how he was
being flown to Germany.
And this is from an IED attack.
I spent five days on the ground
and when I got back from the
assignment, I called and I said
"You know, I think these
pictures are really going to
change the tide against the war.
The public is gonna see them and
turn against the war, for sure."
LIFE magazine asked me to send
the pictures, I sent them
and that was in
November of 2004.
And through November,
December, January, February
they held the pictures and
never published them.
And finally in February I got
an email from my photo editor
saying, "I hate to tell you
this but we will never publish
your pictures of wounded
American soldiers because
we don't think the American
public can handle seeing them."
I was frustrated and angry,
and so I
at that point as a freelancer,
I can then
try and sell the pictures
to someone else.
I called my editor at the
New York Times magazine,
Kathy Ryan,
and she was able to get them
in the next issue of
New York Times magazine.